okay and i want to see if we can get a
message to her but i want to start from
the beginning here i want to
go back into little girl candace the
first time that i ever heard about islam
um the first time that i ever heard
about you know muslims in the context of
a political ideology or religion
and that was the first memory that i had
was in third grade
and we were reading a book and they were
saying
uh in this book that muslim being a
muslim is just like being a christian
islam is exactly like christianity is
exactly
like judaism and we were told that the
prophet muhammad
is exactly like jesus christ i believe
this as a child i think that a lot of
americans that are watching this can
relate to this sort of
of the religion of peace it's just like
christianity
is any of that true so you you haven't
she's very involved in politics now
she's a person who is very outspoken
and some of these people end up speaking
sometimes
out of their lane she didn't have
nothing here she's talking to a person
who's actually not an imam he's like
someone who's put out there
like he's like a fakie mom
help us so uh what would you say like
to someone like her who's probably
listened to your
music from the past for anything but
she's mentioning something so dear to
you
right and she's probably got a lot of
misconceptions in her mind
if you can talk to someone like that
what would you say to her well i would
clarify
what has already reached the
of the connection between
the books that the law revealed the
messengers you know i'm saying in
prophets that allah has consent and
concession
to different nations and that the
prophet muhammad sallallahu asallam
being the seal of all of those prophets
and that their call and their religion
was one
that's the commonality but to say that
they're the same
you know saying would be taken away from
you know a clear perspective and
understanding of what islam end tips
right and i've ran into people like her
and you have to have a certain
sense of concern because one
for a person to even embark on any
understanding of religion
means that they're you know partially
there
you understand as muslims all we're
trying to do is get them all the way
there
you know i'm saying without no deception
we're not trying to deceive nobody
we're only here to convey what is
correct so that it doesn't become a
proof against me
yo mokiyama wouldn't have to stand
before my lord
so to candice and anyone
who's inclined to islam it is our
obligation
to clarify first what is the foundation
is tohit so understand until he
would definitely dispel any notion
that is the same as christianity as his
practice today
versus the religion of israel
during the time of his messengership
which was islam
which was monotheism same thing with
musa
and so on and so forth so you know we
stick to the usual
the people who ascribe themselves to the
sunnah we stick to the usual
meaning the foundation so the foundation
always starts with tohit
no conversation should start unless it
starts with
tohit the pure monotheism so the the so
the the connection between
jesus moses abraham the last and final
message of muhammad is that pure mono
the tohi yeah
but now what people are practicing today
of christianity
worshiping jesus you know people uh
who say that jesus is god there's no
evidence to back that up there's no
there's nothing there that jesus ever
said i'm god worship me but
but if the people look into the true
message of jesus
and all the messengers then that would
you know uh guide you to the right
direction
yeah well there's certain texts that's
in the bible that reside today
that many scholars in the past and in
present and being able
to point out we're told he still exists
in the bible even with all his
alterations in the bible reactions
you know and so on and so forth till he
still remains
so mostly when i talk to christians who
identify with these things and accept
them
but then they find something that
contradicts it and think that they're
debating
but you're only really debating with
your own understanding because you just
affirmed
that none has the right to be worshipped
with god and god alone yeah
right it's in your first commandment
thou shall not place no other god before
me
so we know that linguistically the word
god means object of worship
so now the first commandment makes sense
in the bible
thou shall not place no other god before
me which is synonymous with la ilaha
now you affirm that but then out of the
sake of debating and arguing you want to
find another verse in the same book that
contradicts that one
so the debate becomes with yourself yeah
you understand
and as muslims we have to use hikmah in
these matters it just you know
allow that to pass and then remain
firm upon what they affirm you affirm
that there's only one god
there's only one creator there's only
one facilitator
arranger sustainer organizer of all the
affairs of creation
we agree so if this unique
ability is only deserving of one
then it shouldn't it be his right and
his right alone to be worshipped
that's simplicity people don't like
simplicity for some reason
like complications confusing you know
saying chaos but
i chose islam for simplicity because all
of the distortions and everything that i
used to think
became simplified with the kelly mathen
rasulullah it would follow continuously
and consistently
was attached to that statement yeah
that's consistency that simplicity
and it's lasting and it never gets old
yeah
so someone like her or anybody else now
in the african-american community we
talked
about one what's beautiful about your
life is now if you're seeking purpose
purpose is not in like you said i can go
get the gold chain i can get the car
the massage and then something comes up
and happens and ruins my whole day and
then another stress
you know i make another society tells
you you know what i'm saying that's not
what allah tells you
society tells you that success is based
upon things you accumulate
allah says success is upon belief yes
dying upon belief
living upon belief that none has the
right to be worshipped with allah the
muhammad islam is the message of allah
living upon that implementing that in
your life
and dying upon that that's success
still simple still easy you breaking
down simple so you have that
and then you have the roots there and
then you have that connection with the
pure monotheism
do you think what have you heard these